are you joking me that's why it's a
private story guys
i don't want to get into this again it's
traumatized we laughed so hard it was
like a three stooges prank hey what's up
guys i'm patrick joyner and i play alex
i'm jeremy shader and i play reggie i'm
madison reyes and i play julie
i'm charlie gillespie i play luke and
we're the cast of julian the phantoms
and we're with buzzfeed today to play
who's who
[Music]
who's most likely to forget their lines
or song lyric hey wait
wait wait wait charlie do you just want
to answer this man do you really want to
do this
i have no defense i'm sorry but it it's
probably me
if the line is we have to go to the
dance charlie will come into a scene be
like
guys julie we gotta go
get julie from the video who's most
likely to pull a prank on set
addison addison you had the banana in
the pocket that was legendary
the banana you're right it was it was
very small
like i didn't do much but when i did it
was very big
so i'll take that maddie basically we
were doing rehearsals
in burbank and she just unwrapped the
banana and just
threw it in charlie's back pocket and
they were like decades there and charlie
just
looked like a guy who wanted to save his
banana for later
an unpeeled banana it's like we laughed
so hard it was like a three stooges
prank it was just the funniest thing
ever
who's most likely to randomly break out
into song
oh oh my god owen yes i feel like he was
like
always in that like opera voice like
that broadway voice
when he like was just speaking regularly
i was like yes what are you guys talking
about
you have an awkward voice buddy who's
most likely to
actually believe in ghosts oh and
yeah i feel like he's had the most
experiences to be like
i believe in ghosts all the way guys i
don't want to get into this again
it's traumatizing every time
it hurts me i was laying in bed i'm
having a peaceful night's sleep
and my doorknob starts turning at like
3am and my entire door opens and i look
there's no one there and i go back to
bed and it shouts
you tell me what that was who's most
like their on-screen
character can i say mads i'll go with
mads
it's like what happened to you and like
what happens to julian like the real
world is a very similar thing to what
happened to you in the real world and
that's why i think it's just so
it's so cool you know it is a little
intimidating but you know just like
julie she
has her cool friends her cool band who
helps her through the situation and kind
of like
with you guys with me it's like you know
you helped me through a lot of things on
set and
you know now we're a cool amazing fans
who's least
liked their character on screen
yeah gara has the heart but he's really
smart jared's really a really small
yeah not that reggie's dumb he's just
more simple-minded he doesn't use big
words like jeremy
you're not much of a flirt jer his wife
is around y'all
too i was a hopeless romantic i'm not
much of a flirt kind of dorky and i make
dad jokes who's most likely to fall
asleep
on set all of us i'm gonna say all of us
we've all done it and julie's bed was
definitely a spot that
the pillows i slept better there it was
a little dusty
but nice they're definitely comfortable
10 out of 10. who's most likely to
survive a zombie apocalypse
me and jeremy i feel like we're geek
enough that we know what we have to do
let's go earlier it's me
dude charlie and i are you joking me
i know a lot about zombie movies i've
seen every zombie tv show i think we're
a good pairing man
i think we'll all i think we'll all
survive how about that who's mostly
madison
likely to be madison found that craft
services madison
i'm not trying to call anybody out here
but madison
it's hard especially when i was going
back to school
like it was right there so if i was that
on set for a while
and i was going back to school i was
like oh i gotta grab a snack roast
especially those little brownies
i would get tired so fast running back
and forth so i just needed like a little
bit of sugar
and they did it for me so that's why i
was there all the time who's most likely
to film a secret ig story or tick tocks
of their other cast members
then again madison like i don't go on
snapchat but you go home once in a while
and you see madison snapchats from her
and it's just like random zoomed in
videos of you like eating
that's why they're private that's why
it's a private story
who's most likely to show up late on set
with a cup of coffee in their hand
charlie charlie with no coffee it's a
water bottle oh yeah
i'm hydroflash and he drops all the time
owen would not have showed up to set or
woken up in the mornings if i wasn't
there knocking on his door
who's best at doing impressions of their
other cast members jeremy
jeremy we won't even have voices the
little the little swedish accent
you're too kind i love you guys so much
who's most likely to get caught texting
their crush
gotta text the wife which cast member
would be the first to blab a secret
and which cast member would be the last
to grab a secret
charlie um i'm definitely the last one
to blab a secret i'm gonna say
madison's the first one the broncos
secret okay nice
marley's the last uh i'm definitely the
last i
am the last i'm gonna say charlie
owen me then jeremy oh
get out of here i'd laugh for sure which
two cast members
are most likely to sing a duet karaoke
song but we all did that
yeah but we still did start something
new at the i forgot
oh my god i did
thanks so much for watching go check out
julian the phantoms now streaming on
netflix
bye